hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt ich habe heute ein rezept für
euch führt dass ich wahrscheinlich schon
ganz viele e mails bekommen habe das ist
echt ein rezept was ich ganz ganz ganz
viele von euch gewünscht hatten und zwar
mache ich heute diese raffaello torte
und meine raffaello torte ist etwas
anders als die anderen
ich habe jetzt einen teig gemacht den
ich jetzt auch zum ersten mal gemacht
habe nämlich ein tag ohne mehl und in
diesem tag habe ich kokosflocken mit
drin und auch wandeln weil ja in den
raffaello kugel im innern auch eine
mandel steckt meine creme habe ich so
gemacht dass ich nicht nur seine benutzt
habe weil ich mag das nicht so wenn man
in torten einfach nur seine drin hat
sondern ich hab da auch etwas kokosmilch
mit drin und habe soeben versucht eine
schöne torten creme zu machen
ich hoffe natürlich dass die torte dann
auch sehr gut schmeckt das werde ich
euch am ende des videos sagen
und so sieht sie auf jeden fall aus und
ich zeige ich jetzt einfach wie man die
torte herstellt und was ihr an zutaten
braucht bevor ich es mit dem teig starte
bereite ich schon meine form vor ich
habe zement backblech und meinen
verstellbaren backwaren
den hab ich hier auf 26 cm eingestellt
wie ihr sehen könnt und den werde ich
jetzt in etwas backpapier einschlagen
damit er nicht ausläuft
es kann nämlich immer mal sein dass ein
bisschen zeit ausläuft und ich möchte so
verhindern und dafür nimmt ihr einfach
die form haltet sie fest und legt dann
das backpapier dicht an die form dran
und knickt es einfach und dann habt ihr
vor und könnte auf ein backblech geben
für den teig habe ich hier 150 gramm
butter 150 gramm zucker 400 gramm
gemahlene mandeln
das waren jetzt geschälte mandeln ich
hab hier übrigens mandelblättchen
genommen und habe sie einfach durch den
mixer gegeben und die kleinen gruppen
stücke das stört mich nicht die können
ruhig mit drin bleiben
hier sind 100 gramm kokosraspeln 80 g
speisestärke ein teelöffel backpulver
und eine prise salz und wie ihr sehen
könnt backe ich diesen kuchen ohne mehl
mit ein bisschen stärke und hier mit
mandeln und kokosnuss und ich werde
jetzt noch sechs bis acht tropfen von
diesem bittermandel aroma hinzufügen
dieses mandl aroma passt er perfekt zu
dieser cocos torte
auch im inneren der raffaello kugeln
eine mandel steckt für den rührteig gebe
ich jetzt zuerst die butter in meine
rührschüssel geht natürlich auch mit dem
elektrischen handrührgerät meine mutter
ist jetzt noch ein bisschen kalt sie
sollte eigentlich zimmertemperatur haben
und dann lässt sich nämlich wunderbar
schön geschmeidig rühren
ich muss jetzt einfach ein bisschen
länger röhre und dann gebe ich jetzt
nach und nach den zucker mit dazu und
lass das ganze schön weiß cremig rühren
jetzt gebe ich noch nach und nach die
eier mit dazu und lass es weiter rühren
und zum schluss gebe ich jetzt noch die
trockenen zutaten mit drei einfach alle
zusammen
und rührt es einfach ganz kurz ein und
dann ist da tag fertig dann könnt ihr
den teig in die vorbereitete form
einführen
und dann darf dieser teig bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze für etwa 20 minuten
in den ofen und jetzt müsst ihr den
kuchen nur noch aus der form lösen
danach werde ich ihn mit einem tuch
abdecken und stürzen und dann einfach
komplett abkühlen lassen
danach nehme ich meinen kuchen jetzt
wieder auf einer platte und kann ihn mit
meinem schneider jetzt einmal
durchschneiden
und kann dann den deckel abnehmen danach
setzte ich den boden jetzt auf eine
tortenplatte und zwar setze ich den
deckel drauf und zwar setzt sich jetzt
den deckel als boden hin und den boden
nämlich später als deckel damit ich
einfach eine ebene fläche habt und die
torte schön glatt wird hier stelle ich
jetzt den tortenring außen herum und
kann mich um die trockenen creme kümmern
für die füllung braucht ihr 200 gramm
weiße schokolade 600 gramm schlagsahne
und 150 milliliter kokosmilch
ich habe jetzt hier 100 milliliter und
hier 50 bereits abgewogen
kokosmilch gibt es in so kleinen döschen
zu kaufen die muss man vorher gut
durchschütteln damit die masse wieder
homogen wird und ich habe hier eine
packung gemahlene gelatine
das ist jetzt eine halle gelatine die
gibt's bei mir im shop ihr könnt aber
auch aka tine benutzen oder normale
blatt gelatine bitte sechs blätter oder
eben ganz normale gemahl der gelatine
ich habe mich jetzt für die gelatine
entschieden weil die jetzt in diesem
rezept einfach zu handhaben ist
weil ich die jetzt nicht auf kochen muss
aber ihr könnt das ganze wirklich auch
gut mit ak tine machen so das ganze rein
pflanzlich bleibt die gelatine öffne ich
jetzt einfach und gebt sie mit zu den 50
milliliter kokosmilch verrührt es kurz
und lasst es dann hier einfach quellen
das heißt ich lasse stehen so dass die
gelatine die feuchtigkeit aufnimmt und
es dauert so etwa fünf minuten
in der zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal
die kokosmilch auf meinem herz aufkochen
lassen und sie dann über die schokolade
geben damit die sich schön auflösen kann
damit es hier einfach eingerührt
und dann könnt ihr die schokolade so
lange bis sie sich vollständig aufgelöst
hat und wenn sich die schokolade dann
vollständig aufgelöst hat und die
gelatine wie hier gequollen ist könnt
ihr die gelatine hin mit rein geben
damit sich in der warmen schokolade noch
auflösung haben
und wenn ihr merkt dass sich die
gelatine nicht ganz auflösen will können
dass ihr auch einfach mit der schokolade
zusammen in warmes wasserbad stellen
oder einfach nur mal ganz kurz auf den
herd geben aber die gelatine darf auf
keinen fall kochen was machst du denn da
willst du das ist es abkühlt ok ich
werde jetzt aber in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die sahne schlagen
ihr könnt ihr übrigens mit allem was ihr
macht in der probe machen ich habe hier
vorhinein teelöffel von dieser
schokoladenmasse darauf gegeben dass
film paar minuten kühlschrank gestellt
und wie ihr sehen könnt ist es schon
fest und installiert und so seht ihr
eben operativ gut ist und ob sie eben
funktioniert kann ja mal sein dass immer
aus versehen auf kocht und so können wir
dann noch kontrollieren ob sie noch
funktioniert und verliert jetzt hab ich
hier meine schoko masse die es jetzt ein
bisschen fester geworden bisschen
abgekühlt
natürlich darf sie nicht komplett
abkühlen weil sonst die gelatine sicher
mit der sahne nicht mehr richtig
vermischen müde und jetzt nehme ich
einfach einen löffel dieser sahne masse
und gibt es hier mit rein einfach nur
mit dieser maschine später keine
bröckchen bildet und dann hebe ich das
einfach hier runter
dann können wir euch den tortenboden
nehmen und jetzt etwa die hälfte der
creme drauf geben
ihr seht ihr jetzt noch ziemlich flüssig
aber die wird gleich im kühlschrank
wieder fest
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt in
paraflows nehmen und hinein brüssel
das mache ich jetzt einfach mal einfach
eine andere textur den die torte zu
bekommen so ein bisschen was kranjec ist
dann kommt jetzt der tortenboden als
deckel drauf
und es ist nicht so ein lockerer boden
sondern eher ein bisschen fester aber
dafür eben sehr feucht zum schluss
verteilte jetzt einfach noch die
restliche creme auf der torte und
streicht sie schön glatt
danach muss die torte für mindestens 4
stunden aber besser über nacht in den
kühlschrank und ich texte dazu immer
gern mit einem torten retter ab damit
sie keine fremden gerüche annimmt ein
tag später nehme ich jetzt den
tortenring ab so sieht dann die torte
aus und jetzt werde ich noch etwa 100
gramm sahne schlagen und damit die torte
fertig verzieren
als erstes nehme ich mir jetzt meinen
kuchen einteiler und markiere mir hier
jetzt zwölf stücke ganz vorsichtig
können natürlich auch 16 stücke
markieren und nehme jetzt etwas sahne
und bestreichen hier den torten rand
ganz leicht damit
und jetzt gebe ich an den taten rand
noch etwas cocos streusel für die deko
und drückte jetzt einfach mit der teig
karte von unten nach oben
als ich eben ein bisschen kurios
streusel auf meine teig karte gibt es an
den rand und schiebt es jetzt von unten
nach oben hier an den rand gebe ich
jetzt auch ein paar und jetzt kann ich
hier mit dem spritzbeutel und pasanen
töpfer drauf geben
jetzt gebe ich hier noch eine raffaello
kugel mit drauf
und in die mitte gerne noch ein paar
cocos chips so sieht jetzt meine fertige
torte aus und ihr könnt sehen sie ist
einfach schön weiß dekoriert mit diesen
schönen roche kugeln außen herum mit den
kokosflocken und mit den cocos chips und
wenn ihr jetzt natürlich etwas
farbkleckse mit rein haben möchtet etwas
farbkontraste nehmt ihr einfach
vielleicht ein paar johannisbeeren
blaubeeren könnt da schon noch ein
bisschen was dekorieren aber ich find's
einfach so pur schön weil wir einfach so
erstmalig und leicht aussieht und zwei
man natürlich auch wissen wie sie im
inneren aussieht deswegen schneide ich
die torte an
so sieht sie jetzt im innern aus und ihr
könnt auch sehen hier ist die weiße
creme hier dieser saftige boden noch mal
creme und nochmals saftiger boden
also das ist nicht wie so'n mist mit
boden dass er ebenso ein bisschen
trockener ist sondern das ist ein
schöner saftiger boden das sieht man
hier auch ganz deutlich da ich nicht
luftig und locker sondern erst saftig
und etwas fester und bisschen später auf
eine grillfeier eingeladen deswegen
stecke ich dieses stück jetzt einfach
wieder schön zurück und dann essen wir
später die torte ich denke sie schmeckt
sehr lecker weil sie auch selber sei der
krieg und die creme wahrscheinlich auch
super toll schmeckt ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall ganz viel spaß mit dem rezept
und viel spaß beim nachbacken wenn ihr
das rezept nach pakt würde ich mich
freuen wenn ihr mir ein paar fotos endet
auf facebook oder instagram und dieses
rezept gibt es natürlich auch auf der
liste orten welt.de in schriftlicher
form und ich freue mich einfach schon
aufs nächste mal wieder wenn er lust auf
andere torten habt lasst mich gern
wissen
ich werde auf jeden fall auch mit j orte
machen das ist nämlich auch so mein
absoluter liebling lotto mit viel
haselnuss und ich freue mich einfach
aufs nächste mal bis dahin tschüss